my name is ran i'm a data scientist at
the agmax we provide nlp and
recommendation solutions
and today i'm going to talk to you about
a simple solution that might help you
find a more of your client data
so why do i mean by that so here's our
client
they gather a
lot of information from different
companies different sources
and they all pretty much gather the same
information
but
some use different crms some use emails
some use a snowflake
all of them have different naming
conventions
so
they end up taking the same data and
naming it in a lot of different ways
and that's a problem whenever you try to
to retrieve this data basically you need
to
go to many companies and you need to
join all of these companies together to
one
table
and if you don't know the columns that
you're supposed to join on then
[Music]
you can join it and not only is it time
consuming it's actually
because your sample
isn't random anymore it might actually
introduce bias to your future solutions
so our goal is to build a model this
model gets a column and it will predict
the most relevant column to join with
also because our customer has many
companies the models should be able to
adjust whenever we get a new company to
join the mix
also one of the key
one of the reasons why they came to us
with the project because it took them a
lot of time to join the data together so
this solution needs to be
in real time
so
a customer have a lot of data but
basically what i'm using is only the
column names
so if you think about it in terms of nlp
column names aren't exactly
sentences they don't have the internal
structure
they don't have the the
richness
so what i'm left with is really not a
lot of data to work with
so the first thing i did i took
the logs and whenever i find the join
obviously there's a connection between
the two columns
but what if there's no join it doesn't
mean that there's no information
they just might didn't know
they can do it
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
take the joints that i do know
and then i'm going to train uh an
embedding space and then i'm going to
use this embedding space to suggest new
columns so here's an example of the data
it's not actually the client but it's an
example
so we see that we have a client and
customer
we said have user id and user index
date and date time we know we know it's
the same thing but we also need to make
the model figure out
that it's the same thing
also we have the bucket id that tells us
if they belong together or not and we
also created a depth column that tells
me how many times each column each
column
used to join
so
the overall steps first we need to
pre-process our data and then we need to
figure out the right way to vectorize it
and to measure the distance
and then we can use the nearest neighbor
approach to
to suggest
new columns
so let's start with the pre-process and
[Music]
because we are dealing with a lot of
companies we really need to take it easy
because you don't want to over process
your data
you might end up with a solution that
works great for the companies indeed
instead but doesn't work for the general
companies that will join later
so we took a waterfall approach and
first we have these guys
we have a special characters we have a
capital letters so we broke this
and then we have these guys they don't
have capital either they don't have
special characters any idea how can i
break them
okay no one had a job interview so we
used worldwide and dynamic programming
so the first step is to build the
vocabulary we use the
american large but
column names aren't exactly a word so
they have a lot of abbreviations and a
lot of
technical terms that we had to add all a
bunch of a bunch of these to the
vocabulary
and next we recursively break the words
and each time we check if the
break part is
part of our vocabulary or not but also
we see
that this process is redundant the
last layer is happening before and the
first layer
happens next but it's basically the same
thing so we also keep in memory
everything that we've done before
this way we
save on running time and in memory
next step is spell check
and
for that we use leveraging distance uh
basically we take we measure how many
steps we need to take
to move from one word to another so from
the world form to fork
there's one
and from kitten
to sitting we have a tree
so this is about a
spelling mistake but what about the
abbreviation
so we actually needed to
weight the vowels differently because
abbreviation usually drop the valve
and next
we had to use the data augmentations
here's another example we can see here
the bucket ids but and we have all the
different columns that were joined
together we see that it's not very rich
and we have to use some sort of
augmentation
uh so first we use synonyms we added
random cinnamon synonyms into our
sentences
next we used abbreviate abbreviations we
took a dictionary of abbreviation and we
also created random ones by dropping the
vowels
next we had to create a misspelled word
for our spell
checker and now we need to vectorize it
so the first step was a tf idf
and it didn't work very well
then we tried
world to vec
actually at first we used a
already made world to work a funny thing
the spicy
[Music]
water vector small one doesn't actually
give you a world vector it just gives
you a random
number
so when we fix it to the big number for
the 300 it worked and then when we got
more data we were able to train
a world vector to a
new world to vac
and also we use the depth feature to add
weights by the importance of the feature
and
in terms of distance metrics so why
won't we use the 11 chain distance
so basically 11 levinson distance
doesn't capture the semantic relation we
can see here the difference between
kitten and cat is five
and the difference between kitten
kitten and sitting is three
so the semantic doesn't uh keep
although cats do see it a lot so maybe
that's
something
so we used a constant similarity to
measure the uh the distance between the
embedded vectors
right yeah
and then we use the nearest neighbor and
some would say that's not the fastest
algorithm
actually it worked pretty well for us
but
we can always
accelerate it using gpus using rapids
and
next step is to adjust it for new
companies
so we all know
these examples how we can take a word
and then we can use it to
to perform vector
operations
so we force the company name into the
sentences and now i can use the company
name as a vector
and i can basically move the solution
from one company to the other company
last step is deployment
so we used skln pipeline and a lot of
our solutions needed to be
adjusted so we used a transformer mixing
but when you go to pickle it it doesn't
save all of it it only save the sklm
model so great
so if you want you can actually
if you walk from the current direction
in the
directory that you saved everything
everything works but as you move and
nothing everything breaks
so we ended up moving to cloud pcl that
addressed exactly that
and next we created an api for it and
we closed it in a docker
here we can see some examples
we can see here dtg and we see a
delivery dtg we see a delivery date we
see year and month
we can also see a customer id
a contact id
here we can see
estimated profit so we say we see
estimated margin estimated revenue total
total profit
uh
so in summary this problem seemed uh
pretty complex at start but then when we
broke it apart we found that it's very
simple and elegant solution
be careful not to over pre-process your
data
whenever you can use dynamic programming
instead of a recursion
and use speaker picker cloud instead of
pickle
thank you
[Applause]